you've operated you've invested you've
seen things you saw amazon drop i don't
know what was it 95 in 05 whatever the
year was when the stock went down 95 i
may be wrong on the year
you've seen a lot okay you've seen a lot
of what's happening yeah so
you seem
a hundred percent certain about what
you're talking about which his history
doesn't favor a hundred percent
certainty
you know it it typically you know
and it's not even the i'm not even
talking about the trust but verify
there's got to be an element of
skepticism but you're like no you it's
almost a combination of a
a person who has experience running a
business investor genius but also a
salesperson you're very very good at
persuading as well
are you
a hundred percent certain about
the future of bitcoin and that it has
zero risk there's no risk that could be
anything i don't think you can state
that no i think that everything in life
has risk so there's a there's a black
swan risk an unknown unknown and anybody
intellectually honest has to admit that
there is that risk
that's not what i would say what i would
say is
you have to you've got a bucket of money
let's come back to africa okay
you've got a you've got a hundred
thousand dollars in africa you've got
invested in something you've got to put
it into a building and to land into an
african currency into something else
what are you gonna do
there is a hundred percent certainty
that you're going to lose 80 percent of
your money in most currencies over the
next decade
there's a hundred there's a hundred
percent certainty you're going to lose
95 percent of your wealth over 30 years
in just about every currency and and so
you have to work through each of these
issues and say
what's the cost of doing nothing what's
the cost of not taking a risk what's the
risk-free rate
well i mean the risk-free rate is the
monetary inflation rate so the price
that you pay to not do something is the
rate at which the money is collapsing if
you were russian
they just lost 35 percent of their
wealth by not doing anything in the
matter of weeks so
so in this particular case you just have
to look at the array of options
if uh if you're an investor in uh
south america or asia or africa i would
say
the the risk-free rate is much higher
for you right the ins
like you're in lebanon
what are you gonna do in lebanon how
about afghanistan how about iraq right
what are you gonna do
um in all those situations
they're thinking maybe i'll trust my
money to tether you know tethers run by
bitfinex it's just a company
so why is it that people in many
countries are more willing to uh trust a
company out of hong kong that's running
a stable coin on the crypto network then
they're willing to trust their local
bank
well because in fact tether is probably
a better bet than than betting your
money on
most currencies in the world other than
the top 12 currencies the rest are
collapsing why do tether if you can just
do the us dollar or usdc well you can't
that's the point
why do why do tether if you could just
do the us dollar okay how many people in
africa can walk into a bank of america
in new york city open an account and
then get the us dollar
none of them that's the whole point
right and okay i did it i'll give you an
example i put a million dollars into
bank of america in argentina when the
dollar was worth one peso
because i didn't trust the peso i did it
what do you think happened
the government basically shut down for
one day
they sent an edict to the bank saying
all dollars must be converted back into
pesos
then they went off the dollar peg and
they divided the peso ten to one and i
lost ninety percent of my money
okay
so why do tether instead of trust bank
of america in argentina
you tell me
right because what's the odds that
tether is going to go to zero
in the next year
if the odds were 90 your money is going
to zero in the next year by putting it
somewhere else then you would think
maybe that's a risk i want to take
so you know
people are forced out the risk curve
based upon the monetary policy and in a
hyper-inflating economy in zimbabwe
right you're going to take everything
you've got you're going to buy anything
i don't know if you if you saw um
you'll buy toilet paper you'll buy boxes
of cereal right
you'll buy anything uh there's pictures
in turkey
people and this is this year people go
into uh they go into a a car lot and
they buy all the cars
okay so here's here's the news story
the government in pounds 54 cars that
were bought by a hoarder
someone had the temerity to actually
convert their currency into automobiles
because they thought the automobiles
would hold their value better than the
currency
and then the government seizes their
automobiles
okay if you look at every single war
right the war always has the story of
the speculators right the speculators
the scot the the smugglers and the
hoarders what's your crime
your crime was not holding your money in
the currency which was losing 90 percent
of its value but rather deciding to buy
too many automobiles now your crime was
hedging
right something like that picking at
picking an alternative asset as a
storehouse of what you perceive to be
security until the sovereign comes back
and does one of two things that they're
good at sovereigns know that debt
long term there's the jubilee theory and
also inflate your way out it says or
seize and force conversion which
basically feeds right back into inflate
your way out
eventually that
yeah that all these countries will just
inflate their way out and the currencies
collapse and that's why they're all
collapsing
right the currencies are weaker today
than ever one i i and i think that's
pretty obvious the dollar will also be
printed to pay off the debt
and uh that will just manifest itself
and the dollar continuing to lose value
against scarce assets
it will gain value it'll be stronger
than the other currencies because
they're just collapsing faster so
eventually we'll see a world where
there's a dollar in the cny
right if you're not a very powerful
empire you can't maintain your currency
and that'll be the medium of exchange
and everything will be pegged to it or
correlated to it and then you're going
to see
monetary energy flowing out of weak
property and weak assets into strong
property
like like i would sell all the land i
have in africa and convert to bitcoin
but i would sell all the land in africa
and i would move it to europe and i'd
probably sell my land in europe moving
to the us and i'd sell my land in the
u.s and move it to bitcoin you're just
swapping from a weaker thing to a
stronger thing and the definition of
weak is a function of what's the risk
it'll be seized taxed
or impaired
right regulated right so
calculate that right will the government
the jurisdiction that your property's
nbc's confiscated
taxed away
impaired away and the last the last
issue is we'll be inflated away
right the reason that bitcoin is magical
is because there's only 21 million
um i can create more real estate in new
york city
i can create more cars i can create more
luxury watches i can print i can create
more gold i can create more shares of
stock i can create more bonds
i can create any commodity their
commodities by definition given enough
money and time i can create infinite of
any of them
bitcoin is a scarcity
okay name another scarcity
in the world right and technically it's
not clear there is another scarcity
right a scarcity is something of which
it is absolutely capped if the price
goes up by a factor of a thousand or a
million it is absolutely capped
that is not the case with gold soybeans
silver stock bonds real estate single
family homes ships planes trains
nothing else
everything else could be manufactured
and of course
if the price goes up the the the
incentive to manufacture more will go up
which is why
you know buying a house isn't
necessarily going to be a great store of
value in an inflating economy because
you're going to have incentives for
someone else to dilute the value of your
house if you do buy a house
better off to buy a house on land than a
condo on the 57th floor of a building
and if you do buy it on land better off
to buy it on
on waterfront property
and and if you buy water from property
better off to buy it on the beach
and if you buy it on the beach you're
better off to buy it in the in the most
desirable
location of affluent intelligent people
for the next 30 years sure pat has
scarce pristine that's what you talked
about right you're better to be at
scarce pristine or as close as you can
and that's that and you can do that for
10 20 30 years that's palm beach that's
the hamptons right you can figure that
out now figured out for a hundred years
that's this is the problem right when
you go out for the individual though who
cares for 100 years the individual how
many individuals think a hundred years
though michael institutions think
institutions do but how many even some
institutional leaders only care about
the return they're going to give you for
a decade or two they don't sit there and
think about a hundred years i think
here's the problem i mean that's that's
one of the problems we have with our
current uh uh political system even we
have in america you know the the guy who
gets elected he only cares about two
terms how much can he really do it's
time the issue is the assets reflexive
if if i told you that that uh you could
buy this digital asset and it would lose
its all of its value in 17 years
then people start to amortize it down
and when it gets to be 12 years old
people start to discount it it's like
you don't want to own a building in
london where there's a ground lease that
expires in 37 years right that's not as
valuable as owning the land outright for
a thousand years so if i told you it's
good for 10 years i think and the other
thing is good for a hundred years
everybody wants the thing that's
timeless
and the difference is going to create a
marginal difference in the price let's
say it's two percent or three percent
okay so all the intelligent money go
they stamped in the thing that's two
percent better
and when they stamp anything that's two
percent better liquidity is 10x more and
then the money collapses out of the
other thing and it it goes to zero
that's why bitcoin cash collapses
bitcoin satoshi vision collapses
anything that's sort of like the same
thing but not quite as good
we'll go to zero that's why youtube is
youtube right it's like there there is a
tendency
of winner take all in these things
and uh and it does matter
right now
you have children you have grandchildren
right i i never met anybody that said
you know i just i kind of want to keep
my family generational wealth intact for
12 years but then i don't care anymore
right you sort of care
and and and there's one more element to
this
it's it's not just the ability to know
that the asset will hold value 100 years
out it's the portability
you know if you're living in uh you're
living in nazi germany in 1932
having portable property versus
non-portable property makes a difference
might make a life or debt there are
people that are dead
because they couldn't move the property
right it does make a difference to be
able to move it
so you can't you can't blink your eyes
and teleport a billion dollars of real
estate in los angeles somewhere else in
the world you can't even move it
somewhere else in the country
being able to move the money
from a city to another city from a state
to a state
from a country to a country and from a
counterparty to a different counterparty
all of these things are are
extraordinarily valuable the difference
in life and death
in many cases
and and that's what bitcoin gives you
that you don't get
with anything else so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]